[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by christine frost
aka m and diana silvers aka kate from
amazon's new original movie birds of
paradise out this friday how you guys
doing today good how are you good i love
your funko pops
oh thank you so much yeah no i'm doing
really good i'm excited to talk to you
guys i absolutely love this film
uh so my first question here is for
diana diana talk to me about the process
of building trust with christine since
day one here like how important is that
in a role like this oh man christina is
the best partner and also an incredible
friend and a wonderful person i like i
don't i i don't have enough good things
to even like say like i think i think if
that makes sense yes it does yeah okay i
i like she's incredible and but then
i met her at like a place called hugo's
in the valley studio city area um with
with sarah and instantly i just felt
i just felt like i could i could trust
her like she has such a
she's just
so lovely you're just so lovely like
it's so easy to talk to you and easy to
be around you and easy to work with you
and um
it was building trust was honestly the
the
the easiest part of filming so
um
i'm really grateful that i had christine
on this journey
so chris christine would you say then
that for you guys is it possible in such
a role where you're so intimate with
each other in certain scenes is it
possible to do it without having that
bond that even goes outside of acting
that's a tricky one i mean it it depends
on the circumstance i i do think you
know it's probably possible but and
luckily we had an intimacy coordinator
and they do a lot of amazing work you
know we we had
conversations with the intimacy
coordinator on what we were comfortable
with and what we weren't so even if
diana was awful then
i mean there's certain things you just
can't do these days which is great like
you can't improv in a sex scene so you
know everything is discussed beforehand
but
i would definitely prefer it to be the
way that it was with diana where like i
did trust her from day one and i would
share stuff and we would really go
we'd go deep with our emotions and it
was a safe space that you know i won't
discuss but
but it was it was really it made
everything
so much easier and i feel like it served
the story a lot more as well
no and it totally shows on screen
between you guys like the chemistry is
off the charts but you could see that
trust between you guys in the film which
makes it so enjoyable uh diana i also
was wondering you know you you seem like
a big fan of movies and tv you mention a
lot of it in your posts online how do
you feel about the black swan con
comparisons in this film and did that
film come to play at all for you when
you're prepping for the role um first of
all what an honor to be compared to such
an incredible film i'm a huge fan of
of natalie portman and aronofsky and
mila kunis i mean every
film is incredible um so thank you i've
also
also like wow
um i could never compare myself to
any of that um but i think
um uh for what was the second part of
your question
no i was just saying that you know did
it did you look at that oh okay i looked
at this i actually did not watch black
swan in preparation i saw black swan
when i was like 12 or 13 which maybe
he's a little bit young but whatever i
wanted to watch the film um and i have
not seen it again since then
and i at first i was like oh i should
watch it but then i was like you know
what i don't want to accidentally
like take things from that film into
like my character my performance or this
movie i didn't want it to like influence
any choices i made because like i feel
like i easily could have fallen into the
trap of i'm like oh i should just do
natalie poorman in black swan or
whatever but i just i mean that's her
performance and and
incredible i mean on the oscar
there's just no world where i could like
try to you know so i wanted to do my own
thing and um yeah i hope i hope i did
no but that's what i love about like
when i'm comparing a black swan i'm not
saying it's like anything yeah yeah it's
like it's it's own and it and yeah you
own it your own way it's amazing um
and
christine what i love about your
performance in this there's so many
heavy duty moments with your character
they're very dark and i always wonder
how do you get how do you get to that
place as an actress and is it scary in a
way for yourself to do that it is really
scary i would say so i mean i'm i'm
i yeah it's the feelings that don't feel
i mean like when you're out in the
public you know i feel like there's
certain emotions that we don't really
express as much and and so
it is always intimidating doing that for
the first time but luckily because of
the trust now with diana and and sarah
and the conversations we had beforehand
and everything we
we knew what the scene was about so we
kind of just
showed up and i had my playlist ready
and i i had my own thoughts um
for m and for all of that that i would
just go through beforehand before
shooting it and and then i would just
stay present with diana while shooting
and and then you just kind of see what
comes out and what felt right and
em had a lot of a lot to heal from and
she was going through a lot so there are
a lot of tears
yeah hell yeah i mean and you showed
those tears that i started having tears
watching those scenes so i'm up to you
i've i felt it through you so really
awesome and
gotta ask diana it's the elephant in the
room but in march you posted on tick
tock a video i'm doing tick tock i don't
know what i'm doing is the exact quote
clear robert's appearing behind you
and there's a profile pic of the villain
from powerpuff girls is that it will we
get more tick tocks and is that your
profile
i
do not recall
okay i would like to remain anonymous on
the internet in some way shape or form
i'm so glad you brought this up i have
not seen it
on my instagram it's on my instagram is
yes and it was cool because julia
roberts liked it and commented on it and
i was like
what i love her i'm a huge huge fan i
would like love to work with her one day
but nevertheless um i don't i don't know
i don't think i'll be making any more
talks
you should though if you get reactions
like that roberts just do it um i feel
like that's when you got to stop you're
like okay that's the high moment
true true i like that you keep going i
have private ones
[Laughter]
[Applause]
christine my last question is for you i
have to ask this whenever i see netflix
makes a post
literally every reply is bring back the
society
there's a huge petition still going on
are you over that or do you still see
that maybe a season two will come and is
there hope left for that
oh i mean it's so lovely that people
love the show so much and they're still
wanting it to come back i mean there
were so many things that were unresolved
so i understand yeah i have that with
some of my favorite shows where you just
you want the journey to keep going
oh really that's yours
um well you know it you know it happened
for a reason and and i you know i hope
they can just find their own closure
with it but it's awesome that they're
that they're still watching and wanting
that to happen that's very sweet
yeah no for sure and again everyone
these two are just blowing up right now
they're so talented and to me this film
really shows their range you have to see
it it is birds of paradise it is out
friday christine and diana thank you so
much for joining me and i hope to talk
to you guys again in the future one day
thank you for lovely questions and
energy